(wind blowing)
- You're probably asking yourself
why I'm dangling off a rope a
thousand feet off the ground.
I'm asking the same question.
Well, Disney wanted to make
a show about longevity.
Turns out this has
something to do with it.
Here we go.
(dramatic music)
I'm getting older now.
I don't feel invincible.
It makes me want to push
myself to such an extreme
and live as long as I can
and continue to make the
most of every moment.
(inspiring music)
- if you push yourself beyond the point
at which you should be coming out,
there is a real risk you could die.
- Why am I doing this?
Why am I doing this?
- What's making you nervous?
- Ah, death is usually the big one, yeah.
Whoa.
(dramatic music)
- We want to make you so resilient.
- [Doctor] How can we be
present with our stress now
so that it doesn't kill us later?
- So strong, so powerful.
- If this is going to challenge your body,
it'll challenge your brain, too.
- That you can go toe
to toe with Father Time,
and he's not even gonna bother you.
- We change your body to
do a reboot on your system.
- You know, we're basically
gonna need Chris Hemsworth 2.0.
- The new me.
(inspiring music)
Let's get on with it, shall we?
(upbeat music)